[Aplausos]
eres feliz o solo sonríes
eres una persona que vive las emociones
al máximo te atreves o solo pasa es la
viva la vida sobreviviendo eres de los
que se enamoran y se desgarra el corazón
o la cueva seguro que si eres de los que
defiende sus ideales
terminas haciendo lo que dice el resto
de las personas les voy a decir una cosa
muy importante la vida que tú quieres se
encuentra allá fuera de estas puertas y
no vengo aquí a culparte ni nada yo
vengo a aceptar que yo también tengo
miedo porque la mayoría de las personas
no lo hacemos no nos atrevemos a hacer
cosas porque no tenemos mucho miedo pero
por eso te hago esa pregunta primero no
eres feliz o solo sonríes les voy a
confesar una cosa muy importante mía
yo la verdad hasta hace unos días o hace
unas semanas me hice esta pregunta muy
importante
que ya tengo casi 31 años y la verdad es
que creo que me tarde por eso es
importante que escuchen este mensaje y
les platico un poco de mi historia antes
de que yo empezara a hacer youtube a dar
conferencias a tener las millones de
vistas
yo quería inspirar a las personas y en
puede darlas a través de la actuación y
del canto siempre ha sido una persona
muy soñadora muy soñadora con sueños muy
grandes desde méxico desde monterrey
nuevo león en donde yo quería salir en
la televisión sale una oportunidad en el
2007 y por azares del destino y después
de mucha preparación y de muchos
rechazos y de reinventarme y de pasar
por una fila donde había chavas más
altas que yo mas chaparritas más
peligrosas menos pelirrojas más que
cosas que no decidieron darme uno de los
cuatro papeles protagónicos en esta
serie era una televisora muy grande del
país de mexico
tarda dos años de 2007-2009 y yo ya me
veía decía es cierto estoy logrando lo
que yo quiero sin embargo
al realizar todo eso yo la verdad no
esperaba que no iba a funcionar yo no
esperaba esa reacción entonces me quedé
en un punto en donde que estoy haciendo
si la sociedad el sistema siempre nos
está impartiendo y diciendo que para que
tú seas feliz te dice necesitas realizar
sus estudios de preferencia una
licenciatura en negocios no ingeniería
porque si te dedicas a las artes o a la
comunicación te van a hacer preguntas
como a mí me la han hecho toda la vida
de jay vives de eso
y vives de los vídeos
y como las dos pero no vas con un doctor
y le preguntas eso es cierto entonces al
realizar toda una carrera después
casarte que la sociedad de limpieza
impartir y después de eso tener hijos
dije es seguro que vas a ser feliz así
que mejor toma esa seguridad yo estaba
tomando otro camino completamente estaba
desafiando un poco poniendo a prueba el
sistema y la sociedad y tenía esa luz en
mi cabeza que decía originar tenían
razón tenían razón no te deberías haber
arriesgado claro quien vive de las artes
cierto
pero resulta que después de eso dije no
voy a rendir no voy a escuchar esa
vocecita mala enfrente de mí lo que voy
a hacer es voy a intentar de nuevo y me
reinventé saqué un disco inédito
original y me enfrenté a muchos rechazos
dentro de disqueras en donde me decían
hijo la regina sabes que es que la
verdad es que no estás tan pot o traes
mucho pop y hay alguien que está
haciendo lo mismo o en ese entonces que
era la novela de rebelde el éxito
profundo y ahora fun fun clan de todos
los personajes me decían es que ya está
dulce maría es pelirroja y la verdad es
que nos cuesta menos invertirle a ella
que ya la conoce la gente y sacarle algo
a ella que darte a conocer a ti ojo todo
esto era antes de las redes sociales no
era como ahora que tú te puedes
catapultar y crear tu propio destino yo
salgo después de ahí la verdad cabizbaja
estresada no sabía qué hacer y de pronto
descubro que el management que yo tenía
me estaba robando dinero y recuerdo muy
bien que mi mamá me dijo
regina mejor regrésate porfavor
regrésate a monterrey ya paloma hazte el
famoso dicho y quédate tranquila es una
vida normal estoy una carrera y dicho y
hecho y les aceptó tire la toalla porque
en muchas conferencias seguro les ha
tocado ver donde nadie lo quiere aceptar
yo si les digo tiene la toalla me rendí
y estuve estudiando mercado tengo
internacional muy contenta y para poder
pagar mi carrera guionista un trabajo
entonces digamos que la parte artística
de inspirar a la gente y mandar mensajes
a través de tanta actuación eso ya va y
ya me había despedido yo y de pronto en
cuanto un trabajo de organizar albercada
si me hacen en ser albergadas en donde
yo coordinada a la gente de relaciones
públicas conseguía patrocinios me pagaba
bien era en las tardes y en las noches
fines de semana
entonces yo en la mañana llegaba y iba a
la universidad cansadísima y después de
hacer eso en eventos de marcas y la
gente decía pues que eres muy buena
hablando él es muy buena con las
relaciones te ves bien en este negocio
yo no podía sostener ese estilo de vida
porque llegaba muy cansada a la
universidad y necesitaba sacar mi título
necesitaba sacar mi título porque me
estaba ser feliz invitaba puede alcanzar
ese paso para después casarme y después
tener hijos entonces ya mínimo iba bien
porque recuerden que yo había perdido
como
cinco años entre toda la parte de la
serie y la actuación no tenía tiempo
para perder
así que resulta
y en lo que terminó sucediendo fue
toda esa parte artística toda esa parte
que era regina la dejé un poco en pausa
y dejé de ser yo y empecé el próximo
trabajo que hice era nada que ver
vender casas y estaba yo en bienes
raíces es cierto también es raíces me
relacionaba bien con las personas iba a
los tweets que son de ruta imagínense
pero ya andaba trabajando yo justo a la
misma de mercadotecnia y eso me daba
dinero pero era hasta que vendiera una
casa y me acuerdo que la primera casa o
la 20 única casa que vendí me costó
mucho trabajo pero después de cuatro
meses de insistir de llevar clientes de
ver cómo podríamos negociar funcionó y
dije me gusta pero no me apasiona
creo que esa no es regina esa nueva
regina carrot que voy a hacer no sé así
que renunció a cabo a la universidad y
en eso digo bueno no me voy a regresar a
la parte artística es mucho riesgo pero
tampoco me voy a ir hacer al mercado
creo que ya he pasado por muchas matices
así que lo que voy a hacer ahora es
encontrar algo en medio y había un
puesto muy importante de mercadotecnia
de coordinador de marca y esa
coordinación era de una empresa de
alimentos y bebidas y multinacional que
seguro todos conocen aquí para manejar
la parte de una marca de galletas que
hablaba de poder
y esa marca de galletas tenía 4000
personas de aspirantes que querían tener
ese puesto era otro estilo de casting en
mi vida y gracias a regina bueno eres
feliz o solo sonríes necesito alcanzar
esa felicidad ya tengo mi diploma ya ya
soy egresada de mercadotecnia ahora lo
tengo que conseguir pasó por muchos
filtros y sólo quedamos 12 personas de
esas 12 personas resulta que nos llaman
a la sala de vicepresidentes así como de
película una mesa larga oscura es pura
gente arriba de 50 años que te está
viendo y que no les causa ninguna
emoción en la cara fue ahí donde todo el
mundo presentó quiénes eran ellos muy
formal con pantalón godín igual y con el
gafe siendo lo típico y yo un poco más
rebelde fuera de lo común con unas botas
estampadas hay un pantalón que también
traía unas palabras claro que toda la
gente en la fila me vio y dijeron hijo
qué tonta ya no lo hagan agarrar
y no quedo qué tonta está cavando su
propia tumba resulta que yo me presento
con un vídeo que era un vídeo que grabé
en mi casa que era una canción que me
presentaba y decía todo lo que había
hecho de trayectoria después de esa
entrevista me hablaron automáticamente y
me dieron el puesto y me dijeron que era
por la creatividad que porque a pesar de
que fuera una empresa seria claro vas al
mundo godín que hablar lo respeto
bastante porque yo trabajé ahí muchos
años la verdad es que ellos buscaban
pensar fuera de la caja
entonces yo empecé a ver distintas
maneras para poder ser feliz y distintas
maneras para encontrar mi camino iba
juntas de rotación de productos y empecé
a hacer vídeos de cómo sacarle el poder
a estas famosas galletas para que
finanzas nos comprara la iniciativa
ser feliz resultó que me hice muy buena
en los vídeos y ya alguien decía que
refinar al vídeo tenemos que hacer un
vídeo que hacemos dile a regina no le
hablen a la agencia y abrí mi canal de
youtube sin tener rumbo sin saber que
iba a ser sólo sabía que la reggina
carrot y subía cosas de todo tutoriales
etcétera pero era un hobby de pronto en
una junta muy estresante me dice justo
me dice la directora de marketing
regional a ver ven para acá porque te
noto tan estresada eres feliz dije claro
es que estamos a punto de promover t
estamos a punto de lanzar té para la
ciudad de mexico
queremos traerte tienes mucho
crecimiento vas muy bien y en salud eres
feliz es sólo sonríes y después de mucho
trabajo imagines después de 4000
personas de haber sido elegida para este
puesto y tener algún tipo de seguridad
le tuve que decir sabes que no no soy
feliz porque esta no es mi pasión y la
gente me cuestionaba y me decía regina
pero mira todos los cuatro años que has
invertido en esta empresa de galletas
multinacional que vas a hacer y decidí
no irme a la ciudad de mexico que era la
promoción y me quedé en cero imagínense
de manejar más de 50 personas de
realizarme en mi carrera renuncia a todo
y fue cuando yo estaba leyendo mucho un
libro de dalai lama que decía que la
felicidad se encuentra cuando tú ayudas
al resto de las personas me acordé de si
dije tengo que volver a mi propósito a
inspirar empoderar ayudar yo era una
chava de 27 años imagínense una chava de
27 años haciendo vídeos donde lo veían 5
o 10 personas 200 donde recibirá burlas
críticas la gente se reía constantemente
de mí porque no estaba como de moda y
hoy en día eso de ser influencer
youtuber blogger y en verdad la gente se
cuestiona videncia refinada se le voto
imagina que estás yendo agarrar la
gerencia
y fue ahí cuando dije ya me harté de no
ser yo y voy a hablar de cosas que
vengan desde el fondo de mi corazón así
que empecé a hablar de cosas como el
primer vídeo cuando sientas miedo en tu
vida de cosas como cómo ser feliz pero
no desde el punto de psicología del
consumidor que era lo que veía en
mercadotecnia sino desde el punto de
vista de las personas por eso hice una
especialidad de psicología positiva y
decía es cierto me ponía una gorra para
atrás para la gente que ha visto estos
vídeos traigo tenis siempre a veces ni
siquiera me arreglo y eso fue lo que
empezó a dar crecimiento a la red social
y todas las redes de pronto después de
siete ocho meses empezaron a ser virales
y de pronto esos vídeos de los que todo
el mundo se reía y me decía estás
tirando toda la basura a ver cómo la
estás a morir de hambre imagínense yo no
estaba casada
ya tenía 27 años en muchos lados te
dicen que si no ya eres una quedada para
esa edad yo lo estaba siguiendo el
sistema
no va a ser feliz pobre y esos vídeos de
pronto se convirtieron en no solamente
cinco mil un millón de vistas sino en
100 millones pero a mí no me interesa
hablar de millones y de cuántas vistas y
de todas esas cosas a mí me interesa
poder cambiar vidas inspirar si yo puede
cambiar tu vida tan solo con abrirle la
puerta el día de hoy en la tienda de
conveniencia eso es lo importante y así
fue la primera es que me llegó un caso
que me dice regina por azares del
destino yo soy de ecuador me llegó un
mensaje recomendado tuyo en redes que se
llama con cientas millón tu vida yo ya
había tentado tres veces para quitarme
la vida me dice y gracias a ese vídeo de
sílino y te lo quiero hacer llegar
porque todos los días pongo tu vídeo
este tipo de cosas te dejan fría dejan
frío dejan paralizado un rato y dices
por algo estoy haciendo estos vídeos
para que si le puede ayudar a alguien en
lo más mínimo eso es lo que debemos
hacer
lamentablemente por miedo nos frenamos
no hacemos las cosas y uno de mis libros
favoritos de héctor del poder de la hora
habla de eso dice si tú estás pensando
toda la vida en que va a pasar en el
futuro en que me va a pasar algo no me
voy a arriesgar no vas a hacer nada te
la vas a vivir con fantasmas toda tu
vida necesitas vivir en el ahora es lo
único
y fue lo que yo empecé a hacer vivir en
el ahora un estudio de la universidad de
harvard
agarró en 1955 a 250 hombres y esos
hombres los estudios por 50 años y
querían estudiar cuál era la felicidad
de dónde venía la felicidad de la gente
porque no es un destino no es algo
tangible no es la felicidad no es un
carro un coche una casa ni siquiera la
felicidad termina siendo tu pareja que
dices es que sin ti yo no soy feliz no
la felicidad no se ve y se encuentra del
producto y decía que las relaciones
interpersonales la relación contigo
mismo era lo que daba la felicidad a lo
largo de estos 50 años de las personas
pero deja tú no es que tú seas una
persona social o no es qué relación
llevas contigo mismo les estás dando
gusto toda esa gente ahí afuera
está haciendo tu feliz o estás haciendo
feliz a la gente con lo que quieren que
tú seas básicamente te voy a decir una
cosa es momento de que por favor tú te
atrevas te arriesgues a hacer las cosas
porque igual bien una de esas puedes
acertar debido a que a mí me rechazaron
muchas veces y me dijeron no vas a vivir
de los vídeos no te va a ir bien no vas
a hacer nada en la vida no
después de todos esos millones de vistas
me aprendí una cosa una cosa es lo que
crees que debes de hacer igual te dice
la sociedad tú debes estar casado para
antes de los 30 otra cosa es lo que tú
quieres si tú me dices yo quiero ser
médico o yo quiero viajar por todo el
mundo adelante eso es tu felicidad es
distinta a la mía y otra cosa es lo que
terminas haciendo que normalmente
terminas haciendo nada de lo que tú
querías y solo terminas sonriendo así
que yo decidí borrarme esa sonrisa y ya
está me dolía de estar sonriendo tan
para estar en una persona falsa y
dibujar me a la felicidad aquí adentro
que se encuentra aquí adentro de
nosotros como siendo yo misma siendo
auténtica
a través de ese rollo me di cuenta que
era feliz y esa niña que ven en pantalla
que tiene gorra que ese skater igual y
no es la típica niña que te dicen a
veces sé más femenina cambiarte algo no
vas a pegar bájate escote ábrete un
poquito más
esa niña fue la que terminó pudiendo
dedicarse a lo que más apasionaba y
vivir del arte
y terminé siendo feliz como también
siendo feliz hace una semana en miami
también dándome cuenta que si se podían
lograr los sueños firmando mi primer
libro como me di cuenta que era feliz
que estaba inspirando a la gente
lanzando la primer gira de werthein
mente en américa como me di cuenta que
era feliz porque
que ven en pantalla la pequeña carrot
está llena de cicatrices llenas de
muchos errores llena de muchos rechazos
al día de hoy pero una persona que
siempre quiere buscar lo mejor de las
personas y tratar de inspirar e
inspirarlos el que encuentres esa parte
tuya que sea muy unida así que de
elecciones espero que tú por favor te
des cuenta que es importante a veces
arriesgarte no como decía gene kelly
tienes que proteger tus sueños porque es
algo que nadie te puede quitar
probablemente te lo quite la gente la
gente que no cree y no les fue bien pero
si tú puedes tener la oportunidad de
fracasar en algo que no te gusta el
desear tan solo trata de intentar algo
que amas porque inclusive igual y en una
de esas y les puedes dar así que por
favor elige ser feliz no esperes a que
todo sea perfecto
por favor por favor por favor persigue
tus sueños
esa es la felicidad más importante que
tienes que tener en tu vida así que
siempre les digo a todos baila bajo la
lluvia sin importar que te mujer
escríbele a quien extrañas ya déjate
hacer del lugar no enamórate bien de
alguien y ya vale serenata porque es
mejor morir intentando una y otra vez
que morir sin hacer nada así que te
pregunto por última vez
eres feliz o sólo sonríes
[Aplausos]